[Applaudissements]
bonsoir journée bonsoir merci
aujourd'hui
merci à vous nous régaler et toutes les
semaines j'arrive à faire s'il vous
plaît les idées déjà bourré à très très
très bizarre d'avoir un super nes autour
de la prime
j'étais magnifique d'être très beau
c'est vrai il est beau mais il est beau
benjamin oui c'est vrai il est très bon
face à céret c'est c'est ma vie insuffle
au bon rythme sur un bon rythme et jolly
toutes les deux ouais non géraldine et
qui a lieu le qui se mettent donc
isabelle quand même oui mais je parle
évident qu'un autre qui me regarde c'est
beau la après et après ces robots là
après celle escalade de l'horreur
question bonjour je m'appelle suzanne
j'ai entendu dire que les chroniqueurs
de votre émission étaient grassement
payés à rien [ __ ] dont je n'ai pas de
question mais je voulais dire qu'à
partir de 70 je suis assez dispo
[Applaudissements]
vous postuliez suzanne car c'est vrai
que sur le papier cette description fait
13 ans à tel point que depuis l'émission
de thierry ardisson syrie a déjà reçu 47
mille candidatures prochaine dont
beaucoup de jeunes et heureusement parce
que l'émission ne peut pas se permettre
d'avoir que des quadragénaires qui ne
représentent personne
donc si vous voulez rentrer dans cette
équipe je peux vous donner quelques
conseils déjà pour être un bon
chroniqueur il faut avoir des avis
tranchés syrie n'aime pas les gens
mesurer à des tests pourraient par
exemple gilles c'est bien valérie c'est
caca si vous n'aimez pas quelque chose
dit le fermement toute sérénité partir
il est très ouvert et là on parlait des
prestations sur la finale de the voice
évidemment oui casanova sera mais bon il
est juste candidat mais on va dire à les
lui et chanteurs se rate complètement
non ah si il font pas que des
catastrophes kenji sur adjamé packages
[Musique]
un échec dans le monde
à raison
kenji bordel qu'elle est conne ça
makadji [ __ ]
package bords de l'aar
[Applaudissements]
vous savez qui sera avec nous lundi et
annoncé la semaine dernière mais il ya
tout le temps là et bien sûr à sanaa
parce que j'attendais tellement de se
tromper de date
kenji de leur moto et tous pas tout
c'est trop mignon ma chérie
mais moi ce serait bien bon on a bien
rigolé ouais mais vous l'aimez camji
cola non pas du tout je déteste
kenji mêlée il est sympathique et il est
beau il a beaucoup inquiété ses fans
parce qu'il est très amincie et alors eh
bah oui mais par l'été vous devez moi je
moi je n'ai pas préparé je me retrouvais
comme un conte sur la plage niro - kenji
va être beau gosse voilà castaldi à
préparer l'été voilà il est beau besoin
est redevenu beau et fit assez vrai bon
maintenant il faudra lui enlever des
voix les boissons
si en plus vous quand vous êtes
chroniqueurs vous pouvez dire ce que
vous voulez aller rien soit kenji away
autre point très important s'il va le
confirmer
le chroniqueur il faut bien préparer ses
émissions à huy et connaître les invités
aujourd'hui on acquis
kelly comment il s'appelle n'a pas bien
comment gilbert et on a donné du bois
très bien à balconnet me benoit dubois
donc il faut bien que la légalité ou en
tout cas à réussir à le faire croire
tout de suite une démonstration de notre
maître à tous mathieu de leur bourse
les personnes tous les quatre mois j'ai
tenu et vous la princesse erika
[Applaudissements]
monsieur et neymar tout de cette envie
de changer la couche fine attitude c'est
l'écart faire ça c'est énorme ça tu t'es
dutrey gall n'ont pas trop bas côté et
puis trop j'aimerais président iranien
faites attention à vous serrer des
menaces après coup de pression y voilà
c'est pas de chance elle a joué dans ton
est émis ce matin
ouais il a perdu 1,8 g gagner moi je
fais le même tournoi j'ai gagné ouailles
on n'a pas le même destin humain
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
or donc ce qu'on m'a dit qu'on l'avait
vu passer et leila il a vraiment perdu
très très vite à 6 2 6 0 très vite
j'aurais pas aimé que ça arrive ça ne
soit jamais arrivée au nom vous arrivez
en f1 vous aviez perdu aussi a
facilement pas paris july se gagner à
personne que tu es très fan de foot va
dans ce sens ce que j'ai dit vous perdez
beaucoup
non ça c'est moi qui l'avais dit dans
l'émission et c'est vrai non je crois
que j'ai gagné mais j'ai voilà donc je
voulais dire fait destination petit
point mais qu'on embrasse d'ailleurs
votre fiancée quand même beaucoup
j'espère qu'on va gagner un set et demi
et moi je fais une raclée
merci bien sûr mais ils sont elle même
n'est pas bourg elle est comme ça petit
tour benneteau alors pour trouver sa
place dans l'édition il faut aussi va
évidemment de l'humour et les meilleurs
on est l'exercice et qui sait bien sûr
jean michel et maxime
ah ouais il rebondit surtout ils sont
très vifs là je devais répondre à une
question de culture générale concernant
la devise de la devise de la ville de
paris je rappelle que je suis d'origine
vietnamienne les lourds annonce ce jour
son plein que tu as nec mergitur c'est
quoi merci à tous est aussi la devise de
paris ne coule pas maël quoi d'autre ne
coule pas c'est elle tangue mais ne
sombre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et l'autre qui rajoute derrière think
tank est sorti naturellement ah oui
c'est bien c'est bien c'est tout
naturellement n'ait pas été disque dur
et puis parfois ça arrive le meilleur
chroniqueur du soir c'est l'invité et là
je vous ai attribué une mention spéciale
à amel bent qui était elle était en roue
libre la semaine dernière treize enfants
mais tellement naturel je l'adoré ahmed
alors au départ ça a commencé avec une
image de mac lesggy dans la rubrique de
camille combal vous allez fra amaël va
affirmer quelque chose qui va mettre
très mal à l'aise jennyfer non légale m
qui sont là juste qu'on n'aurait jamais
aimé voir ma caisse dire on flippe non
de traces
colombo gauche
[Musique]
c'est l'une jour là cet ancien sa
remontée
[Musique]
samedi ghadames qu'il avait bien caché
il a passé sa feuilleton passionnant de
paris est plutôt subversive bon à la dhr
et sulfureux contrairement à ce qu elle
a des cheveux du temps sachant garder la
même vidéo de lui qui saute de regarder
et il est vraiment utile et progresser
le jour
[Applaudissements]
on n'est pas des pieds lui faire aussi
mais que les deux ans vous aviez un an
et demi c'est long très long l'adorable
être un polochon ça va vous appeler
comme ça maintenant
non mesdames à vos yeux vous appeler
paul au torchon grands noms le c'est pas
très grave
allez on passe au vote objets danse ces
petits moments embarrassants qu'on
aurait préféré ne pas voir dans tpm paix
[Musique]
à l'eurovision qui a cartonné 5,2
millions de télé c'est le record c'est
le record piste c'est hambourg où il a
l'habitude était de 5 millions 7
téléspectateurs c'était au moment où
cyril hanouna
[Musique]
c'est la saint maurice à ce soir chez
paris/saint-denis sco
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un certain 1 200 perdreaux par terre et
ça me fait toujours un drapeau jaune est
au top
[Musique]
ben oui monsieur quoi
[Applaudissements]
amina contre bolton
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
amel bent bon rennes volley
exceptionnellement naturel hamel roudaki
femmes et était la meilleure du monde
qu'est-ce que j'ai ri alors stop j'ai
pensé que c'était juste avant la pub
j'aurais aussi pu être le bisou manqué
entre kelly ayotte
après les avant-dernières qui attire est
ce que vous vous souvenez m'a mis un
petit rappel pour vous rafraîchir la
mémoire
je demanderai au public de ne pas
applaudir la fin des extraits car c'est
un moment un peu le sens que je vais
quantum et un décolleté ou courmont de
ses fesses on sait très bien
pertinemment quoi gérer on n'est pas
d'accord avec les réseaux sociaux mais
on sait que ça va arriver
non
[Applaudissements]
toi petit bisou c'est un succès c'est
qu'on prend pas en compte cette virée
oui c'est dur
enfin moi j'avais pas sorti comme ça que
c'était dur mais apparemment c'était dur
parce que le soir même et eu des
articles partout sur voici.fr à gâteau
proulx et kelly vdev lice cyril hanouna
lourdement de son passé elle refuse ou
là le site de rtl belgique a faites vous
un petit bisou c'est vrai tout ça
arigato peau et qui les vident les
listes des tests tels vraiment le site
de télé star aussi même si tu sens que
ils ont pris leur parti
gênant si red herring a ainsi lourdement
au clic et libido velits et gâteaux
proulx s'embrassent alors comment en
sommes-nous arrivés là c'est un bisou
gates
moi ça m'a fait froid dans le dos mais
je sais bien moi aussi je n'ai pas dormi
aller chercher j'ai gratté moi je vous
le dis franchement j'adore les deux bah
oui c'est vrai c'est courageux
[Applaudissements]
tout à votre honneur
c'est comme deux soeurs bao di piscine
famille exactement parce que c'était pas
grand chose de faire un bisou alors j'ai
des explications c'est pas le montage
vous avez vu avec les rayons laser qui
les attendus parce que vous avez au
contraire la séquence et a fait marrer
tous les deux s'étaient même super
complices sauf qu'à la sortie du magnéto
agathe va glisser une petite phrase à
kelly et tout voir partir en sucette la
trêve la plus courte de l'histoire
quand on met un décolleté ou cours monde
s'est fait 111 on n'est pas d'accord
avec les réseaux sociaux mais on sait
que ça va arriver
non
[Applaudissements]
c'est là j'adore parce que agathon
google
lp jean elle dit ça comme si le médecin
qu'on nous allons recommander la place
et est ce que vous l'avez occasion les
deux répartir après plus de bisous
saturant vous en êtes vous aujourd'hui
toutes les deux c'est sûr pas disent
d'accord ça va s'arranger très bien vous
savez j'ai un projet j'ai un projet de
vous vous mettre toutes les deux faces
et vos frasques un suspense avec des
bonnes notes et de vous lâcher comme ça
loin de la civilisation oui et vous avez
quelques jours pour retrouver la
civilisation toutes les deux avec
massages et tifa comme le film américain
la chaîne à un film d'horreur alors
centipede bah ouais ça vous fait pas un
intime d'or à l'arrêt et dur et quand ça
va ça va s'arranger vous êtes très
sympathique toutes les deux il ya aucune
raison qu'on ne vous entendiez pas voilà
que c'est vrai qu'est-ce qu'il ya de
leurs books mais rien monsieur ribéry du
tout géré il dit écoutez on va très bien
merci
aller chercher du thon ou peut-il aller
j'ai l'impression d'hésiter une thérapie
de compte et jamais il n'a pas dix ans
né à un couteau il a tué moi en fait
vous faites une émission c'est gentil
toute la saison alors est-ce que je peux
enchaîner série les aventures de maxime
maintenant avec les phrases non à la
bombe à passagers semaine prochaine il
faut qu'ils reviennent déjà maxime
revient deux fois par semaine quoi qu'il
arrive je le dis avec simon a explosé
son contrat aussi dépendants et son
contrat c'est deux fois par semaine les
aventures de maxime cdc nouveau oui
c'est une nouvelle séquence car en
regardant tous les os je me suis aperçu
que maxime c'était comme martin il ya
plein d'activités différentes
un jour il un scoop it aux régions il
fait des tours de magie un jour il
disparaît pour être bien d'en faire une
série avec des épisodes plus ou moins
long en fonction n'a réussi de ces
initiatives tout de suite le premier
volet de cette saga
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais bien vivre
pour me payer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
charismatique vous m'aviez a composé un
prix d'ailleurs mais combien au moins
100 euros
non non non j'avais 10 50 euros ouais
pour le vert sur la vraie remise alors
que je reverserai tort je vous donne un
cours semaine prochaine avec plaisir à
laisser le sais j'ai un très bon revers
mais robert je sais que ça vous connaît
c'est la presse ah bon il y en a un peu
plus jeune mais quand même vous pas vous
l'attendez maximo j'ose même pas nous
réserve bien sûr aujourd'hui mais j'ai
du mal à suivre vos conversations très
décousu allez on commence par un scoop
incroyable de cyril hanouna de vous vous
en foutez meyjes tableau je suis témoin
oui je suis là donc je vais balancer un
truc sur quoi sur moi sur un scoop c'est
un scoop que vous avez lâché sur un
joueur de l'équipe de france de football
qui équivaut mondial sur adil rami non
[Musique]
mick mc
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
chopra
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais en tout cas je souhaite énormément
mais vraiment énormément de succès
vraiment à camille je vois là je les
aime énormément je me mets à la place du
téléspectateur je me demande 1 est ce
que vous êtes francs cyril a franchement
première leçon sur le bouchon pas avec
les films garçons moi je me demande s'il
n'ya pas plutôt un problème de rythme h
mais je pense qu un ballotin productrice
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
blanc
j'ai 25 ans donc on ne va pas changer ta
la même tête
salah des pieds benhaim le poser
nous on comptait en moyenne mais qu il
faut arrêter sur intelligente après
c'est pas de toi alors
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]